citizens of the reject Nation we
leave for the Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 premiere in like 40 minutes
so we gotta rush to get this up and we
got the help of someone to help us cover
the Hunger Games who's a big fan of the
hookers actual literature person over here
Michael Tessler you did something do you
I'm bigger there's something different about
it did you get an all new teeth I'm doing my
Caesar flickerman well leave a like for Michael's
commitment because he literally did it just for
this one trailer I also want to say uh thank you
to everyone who has followed us at our patreon
um why are you mention patreon in this video well
recently uh all our videos on patreon WE upload
um everything in our Vimeo and we're charging
us a hefty bill so with that in mind we got a
sponsor for today's video fellow Space Cadets
it's time to blast off into the final frontier
with the help of today's video sponsor Star Trek
Fleet command today's video sponsor I've been
playing this game for the last 90 minutes so You
Bet Your Butt Talks I am ready to talk about this
game it's free to play open world MMO game puts
you in the captain's chair of your very own star
base on the front lines of a Star Trek universe
where you can construct fleets of your favorite
chips and recruit legendary officers to your crew
explore strange new worlds seek out new life and
civilizations and dominate the Galaxy with your
powerful Starships with the ability to customize
your Fleet and set your sights on expanding your
territory eliminating Rivals exploiting resources
and exploring New Frontiers this game is the
perfect way to Unleash Your Inner Kirk or Picard
or data or many of the other 100 characters
you can populate your Fleet with imagine
commanding alongside your favorite officers
and living out all your space exploration
fantasies it's enough to make a pharyngi grin
from ear to ear I pulled out one so get beamed
up reject Nation join the millions of players
already exploring the Galaxy building their
fleets and competing in Space Battles click
the link in the description box or scan the
QR code right here on screen to download
Star Trek Fleet command today and boldly
go where no one has gone before I wanted
to pun-centric it a little bit you know
[Music]
John Wick I am honored to introduce to you
the creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean Casco oh no way damn I didn't know he was
in this creators I've summoned you all here for
the 10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district to fight
to the death in The Hunger Games from District
12. Lucy gray bear is becoming a superstar man
there has been a change this year as the mentor
Mr snow Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles no what does my mentor do besides
bring me roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in that
Arena start by thinking I can actually win
believe I'm lucky flickerman first ever
host of The Hunger Games he's doing great
enjoy the show what a Lo-Fi Hunger Game
what happens in there filled
with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become Predator see how quickly
civilization disappears oh my goodness the push
there's a natural goodness built into us all
the fight against it we can step across
that line into evil I think that's 13.
you hear that boy it's the sound of snow falling
that is not snow what is action it's perfect
perfect for this how wonderful that we all
get to be here for someone's final performance
everything is about winning yes [Applause]
I don't know
whoa and bird Gorman
the things we love most Try Us
Color Me interested people groovy I not going
to lie did not have much of an interest in this
really haven't wow and that trailer just reeled
me back in yeah they cast their hook with their
marketing and they reel me back in for some reason
when I heard prequel I thought that there wouldn't
be any actual hunger gaming here I was like
oh no there's like a Hunger Games thing and
I was reminded how the last couple movies there
was no actual hunger games and then I'm like oh
this is gonna be cool this is an actual hunger
games again yeah uh so yeah like I don't know
the literature I've only seen the movies but I I
thought this was a great great reminder of what's
come before at the same time you know getting
some familiarity with the Nostalgia of some
of the characters that we are familiar with and
it's always fun seeing like the younger casting
and whatnot uh it looks like a better version of
whatever the hell that fantastic Beast franchise
was supposed to be because that's a great point
before we let you take this away Michael John
who's in the same boat as me unless you've read
the books did you have not son of a [__] better
uh no this this pulled me back in especially
because the first two Hunger Games movies uh
had my my interest in my enthusiasm a lot more
than the later two and so this yeah just brought
me back to like the Intrigue of the world the
Vitality of you know the the conflict that the
games themselves present and two seeing is what
like 60 or 70 years in the past from the Katniss
stories so like I also just love the blending
of so we should see young baby Katniss at some
point yeah baby embryonic 75 when she competes
completely differently in this world um and at
first too I was like really Cory Elena snow we're
gonna that guy but even if even his role in this
and then seeing how you know I imagine how he
kind of Begins the rise to the status we see
him in later movies like I don't know this doesn't
feel like a contrived way to keep this going this
feels like another spot on the map that we're
shining a light on yeah it looks like he starts
off compassionate and then you watch him grow into
uh cold-hearted son of a baby I always thought he
was the hero uh no I I have always loved Hunger
Games uh my crush in high school was like you
should read this and so I did and she's like you
remind me of Gail uh and that's exactly how it
turned out for me so uh yeah I lost that to a guy
named after bread uh what a sad way to go sorry
but what'd you think of this trailer Brothers
you got three minutes trailer uh well first off
they set such a cool interesting tone of the
early capital and the early Pan Am I love where
the world still feels a little dystopian it has
this like retro futuristic element that you don't
quite see in the original Hunger Games films from
like a style perspective like Count Me In from a
lore perspective like I'm so jazzed about the and
the amount of World building that we saw even just
in this trailer was just like golden um I don't
want to spoil anything for those that haven't
read the book so I'll be like super Broad in my
like contextual knowledge here did you read the
book yeah because that's what I say all the time
from every comic book and every show I can't read
I read it so fast I don't want to spoil it for
you so I'm gonna be like bro bro no no it's a
super fair but I don't know how to read Greg so I
couldn't even if I tried time you have two minutes
oh damn it uh there is a really interesting the
house of snow oh which is ironic considering you
know some of our Game of Thrones characters that
are in the trailer uh the house of snow has fallen
from grace and you have the future President Snow
uh who's really kind of given the mantle to try to
bring his family uh The Prestige that they used
to have uh and I think seeing how a character
who is dynamic complex there's a lot going on
with President Snow I I recently rewatched all
three of The Hunger Games and it really struck me
like they hold up they're really good um and this
is a fascinating Deep dive uh in a lot of ways it
mirrors Katniss's story because it does feature a
tribute from 12 uh and if you re-watch the Hunger
Games with the context of this narrative it makes
President Snow's actions uh and Arc all the more
interesting and so it's nice to see a prequel that
is going to feed into and enhance a story rather
than just telling an extra story just because they
want to make more money yeah yeah well I'm excited
that Peter Dinklage Peter Dinklage Peter I'm
excited he's going to be in this world he's the
perfect kind of actor for this I just rewatched
Infinity war or he's Eatery his greatest role his
greatest role ever and then his biggest role the
Rachel Ziegler uh Zeigler Ziggler [Laughter] she's
just like on the rise and [__] like she does
phenomenal work consistently back to back to back
uh so I'm really excited that you know she gets to
be the new Jennifer Lawrence get her and Jenna
Ortega together in something and they'll fuse
into like a Megazord put them in a peanut butter
Factory I would love to see them dipped in peanut
butter and then mush them together with some
jelly peanut butter was not invented by Latino
woman no it's true I don't care why you guys
accuse me of racism I I just assume as a white
person always protecting myself Against Racism
George Washington Carver Critter peanut butter
and the did he do the pistol sharpener too what
was that one cartoon that's oversimplified that
guy's life so much that would be the proud family
this is what I was worried about we gotta go to
the premiere thank you guys so much for being
here what do you think I told you what I thought
oh I'm talking to them what did you think there's
someone else in the room when you said what did
you think and what do you think of the trailer
guys put it in the comments do you like Michael's
hair should this be as permanent 73rd annual
hunting games John um follow him on you don't need
to but I need followers if you find me in public
follow me around for five minutes myself and buy
foreign